[Music]
there is a secret world of trolls it is
now your charge to protect for you for
the troll hunter this is a magical show
and it has love in it and joy we're
making a series that has a different
approach to lighting and animation in it
that's beautiful
I'm not surprised because game was
filmmaking is such a feast for the
senses fans of sci-fi fantasy adventure
comedy this is a show for them but also
get to blow some adults away as they're
watching with their kids that cool thing
I wanted to show you this is it well
pretty much this one unlikely chosen
hero is selected to save our world
he is our troll hunter oh cool is that I
wanted us here is that have a lot of
mythology behind it but dealt with kids
that were very regular your only thing
now you want your life to be more
exciting right what I've always loved
about pmo is that his imagination knows
no bounds
there are secrets revealed magic that
occurred it looks awesome
I'm very proud to having done a series
that is fantastic
there's a poetic component to it and a
magical component to it a wonderful
beautiful spectacular show for everyone
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
date o'clock we're so late our kids are
gonna have detention come on come on so
beneath your feet there is a secret
world a vast civilization where good
trolls live and evil trolls lurk for
centuries these lands have been
protected by one warrior give me the
amulet troll hunter I'd rather die
the amulet will find a champion whoa
Master Joe who have been chosen Oh Jim
you are now responsible for the
protection of two worlds human and roll
alike that if you do not protect us hula
and his army will destroy your world
fine
I knew you had potential you have a
sweet voice but you bring death with you
the fight is within you are you ready
the amulet of day life challenges you to
ascend to the most sacred of offices
you muster gym on a troll hunter
so there's nowhere to go but up when you
should begin your training now I had two
wives to keep up who are you Jim Lake
you've got a great look
do your worst
oh wow Oh Carl's waah dance fight
[Music]